[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road 2000
as always my name is caleb denby and my
hair is slowly eating my face
tonight i wanted to stay topical as
always with the road
and talk about a chess player who's been
recently talked about quite a bit online
and that is
hikaru nakamura of course the car has
made quite a name for himself in the
streaming world
and is pretty solidly cemented as one of
the
best if not the best online rapid and
blitz player
of all time but tonight i wanted to take
it back a little bit in time
to hikaru's slightly earlier days before
he joined
thechest.com and twitch.tv crew
and talk about his over-the-board career
and where it is at
now and where it was at about 10 to uh
five years ago so many of you might know
that hikaru actually peaked at number
two
in the world that was all the way back
in 2015. he was well above
2800 i think he was like 28-14 or
something
and number two in the world second only
to magnus carlson
and they actually have a very
interesting over-the-board record
and that's what i want to jump into
tonight so we're going to take a look at
what happened
between magnus and hikaru back in the
early 2010s
and see the conclusion of that rivalry
let's take a look so to start with i
want to show you a pretty typical game
between magnuson and karu way back in
the day
so the story tonight is going to be
hikaru's
sort of mental block against magnus for
some reason whatever reason it may be
even when hikaru was at his best he
seemed to have some sort of block
against magnus carlsen just couldn't get
a win in against the guy
and was struggling with games like these
so
here magnus had the white pieces and
we're going to take a look at d4
d5 c4 c6
oh and by the way let me check the tags
let you know where this game was played
this was the sink field cup in september
of 2014. i was getting my my games mixed
up so this one
september uh 2014 sig field cup we get
uh not c takes d4 we get knight c3 and
this move is sort of
uh asking for d take c4 i myself with
white pieces here i like to go knight f3
keep it a little bit simpler that way if
black has any
clever ideas about taking on c4
i'm a little bit better prepared to deal
with recapturing this pawn for example
after b5
i can go a4 and i don't have to worry
about b4
attacking my knight on the other hand
here magnus plays the move 3
knight to c3 and now after d takes c4
we're going to see a very similar line
but after a4 black does in fact have
this move
b4 hitting the knight on c3
um so what does this mean for white's
position well
it means if you play like this you just
have to be a little bit more prepared
these lines are fine for white from what
i can tell
but you do have to know a little bit of
theory which of course magnus does
in this case this knight has to move you
can actually move it
to pretty much any of these three
squares but 94
is the main line might as well stick the
knight in the center
now we get queen to d5 hitting the
knight and pressuring g2 a little bit
and magnus actually brings this knight
back to d2 just
already increasing the pressure on this
pawn no messing around
we just want to take our pawn back
however
black has further ideas here and caro
simply pushes the pawn further down the
board
bc3bc3 and now it looks like it is
actually going to be a little bit
annoying
for white to regain this pawn and so
white's knight completes
its little round trip here and heads
back to b1
uh of course it's every chess player's
goal to move the knight four times by
move nine
just one of those funny lines where it
seems like both sides are wasting a lot
of time
but this is the kind of funny business
that you have to do in order to
regain the c pawn in this line any time
that white is wasting
by moving the knight around black is
also actually spending this time
trying to keep the pawn alive so it's
not as if magnus is making some great
sacrifice in time here
uh because the car was also spending
just as much time to keep the pawn alive
and to that point we see hikaru actually
move the queen again
over to a5 again just trying to keep
this
uh alive and keep himself in the game
now we see queen to c2
and very very surprisingly uh hikaru
plays
a pretty serious inaccuracy here so the
main line
is actually going to be knight to a6
here it's just time
for black to give up on this pawn no
reason to keep fighting for it
um you don't actually expect to keep the
pawn when you play d
take c4 in the slav and here
white can play something like queen c3
in the best game i could find here
was actually a game between um
alexander kustinik and let's see who
else
it was here oh and gear yeah had the
white pieces against alexander
castaneuk and that game went like this
black just sticks this knight onto b4
and with the support of the queen and
the bishop it's actually quite difficult
to remove this knight and then both
sides are going to get developed here
knight f3 knight of 6
bishop c4 obviously the knight is
preventing the bishop from going to the
natural d3 square
we see both sides get castled work to c1
and at the end of the day black is going
to be just in time to break
with this move c5 and when the dust
settles
after you know c5 and these two pawns
get traded
black is pretty much equal if you can
achieve this in the slav
you have pretty much equalized you know
negating white's central advantage
opening the lines for your own pieces
and in this case black is perfectly fine
so what did hokkaido do instead well
instead of knight a6 akara tries to keep
the pawn
with a little bit of a tricky move in
the form of e5
of course what black is hoping for here
is
you know if you're really dumb you play
queen take c3
and lose the queen but i think acara was
specifically hoping for
knight takes c3 when of course white
isn't losing
but you do get a little bit more fun
than in the other line rather than just
equalizing
black is applying quite a bit of
pressure to the dark squares in white's
camp
and is going to saddle white with this
isolated pawn
and perhaps black will be the first to
castle the first on the e
file and white is going to have some
some work to do to to get back into this
game
but of course magnus carlsen had
something better in mind and i don't
know if this was actually prepped
by magnus i imagine it could have been
because e5
seems like a move that you should check
if you're playing this but
this move basically just gives white an
advantage and this is why it's so
surprising to see ikaru
making this move pawn to e5 now i
don't want to uh you know
speculate too much as to why akara makes
these strange decisions against
magnus or made these strange decisions
way back in the day
but this is not such an uncommon theme
you see caro doing something a little
bit
funky uh as he was known to do sometimes
but against magnus it just doesn't ever
work out right magnus just finds good
chess moves
but uh chat room here how do we gain an
advantage with whites
after this move e5
how do we gain an advantage with the
white pieces
what to do
and someone in the chat was guessing
bishop f5 i don't think those tactics
actually work
we can just take and if you play c2 i
can move the knight
to block the check and remove it from
the threat of capture
so those tactics not so good for um for
black
uh so basically the point of white's
next move
is that it makes black's plan of knight
a6 to b4
a lot less feasible it makes it so that
this idea is not going to be so workable
at least in the immediate future and
this is why e5 is a little bit of a
mistake so what can we do
to make knight a6 to be for a little bit
less
uh feasible or reasonable whatever you
want to say
seeing a lot of moves being suggested
here but none of them really
to the point
yeah a lot of ideas in the chat and all
these moves i think are
you know maybe okay but uh if you just
play some normal developing move like
knight a3 bishop a3 bishop c4
black is still going to take on the d4
pawn
and open up this e file and again black
is maybe going to have the
the better side of things with white
having this isolated queen's pawn
and uh having a little bit of work to do
in order to complete development with
this annoying pawn still on c3
so knight takes again just the same plan
by black is going to be perfectly fine
there we're going to take on d4 play
bishop b4
and have a little bit of pressure yeah
queen e4 is a little bit too much
what you want to do here is develop your
pieces and prevent black's natural plan
and the way to do that is actually with
the simple move knight to f3
why is this move so strong well first
and foremost you're threatening to win a
pawn
and if black continues with what seemed
to be the plan here of e takes d4
we're simply going to take back with the
knight and the point now is that we
don't have this isolated pawn to worry
about
our e file remains closed and our king
remains safe
and now um we're actually applying a
little bit of pressure to the c6 pawn as
well so move like knight a6 now
it's going to be very difficult to
achieve with all this pressure on c6 so
sometimes the simple move is correct
here and you just want to find these
multi-purpose developing moves
that also hamper the development from
the opponent so
that's generally the best you can hope
for in the opening sometimes you can
just win material outright
but you want to find the best way to
develop that keeps
your king this your king safe and also
hampers your opponent's development so
always be on the lookout
for these kinds of ideas and so the car
was actually
uh so unhappy with this line that keeps
this knight on b8
sort of hemmed in of course you can play
something like bishop b7 or bishop d7
here
but then you really are asking for some
trouble in the form of something like
queen to e4 check on occasion
uh also just simple development here and
this uh stuff with knight b4 is just
coming a bit too slowly
now that white is able to castle now
knight b4 is actually no good because we
can just take
i actually forgot to mention in the
other line there was a knight c2 tactic
taking advantage of the king on e1 um
so knight a6 just isn't really feasible
so the car was actually so unhappy
with this development in the opening
that he decided you know what i
i'm just sacrificing this e5 pawn which
makes some sense but at the same time is
going to cause some serious trouble
so magnus goes ahead and captures but
now uh hikaru is
getting this knight to be for idea in
the problem here for acaro
is that it's like the normal line except
you know
he doesn't have an e pawn and e pawns
are are generally pretty useful
believe it or not so white is is just
significantly better here
uh with the extra e pawn and this is the
type of strange game
that hikaru would really only get
against magnus carlsen
you don't you didn't you never really
saw hikaru making these mistakes
these early opening blunders um against
anybody but
madness at least that's the way i
remember it
and so white does still have some some
work to do here
i should mention of course if we play
queen take c3 there is still this
winning idea by
black of knight to c2 check and the
queen is actually pinned
and the knight delivers checks so queen
takes is illegal the king has to move
and then of course black is picking up
the rook on a1
so queen c3 not going to cut it but
magnus simply slides out of the way
with queen to b3 not hampering the
develop the development of this bishop
and now it's just simply winning for
white the game continues with bishop b6
and from here on out it's smooth sailing
uh bishop c4
for magnus c2 simply um
knight to d2 is perfectly fine for white
here it's plus three in winning
but magnus of course finds the best
continuation which is to actually just
capture
on e6 with the idea being that if black
tries to queen here
we're just going to take and take and
this king is
entirely busted up here there's no
knight c2 anymore because the rook is no
longer
on a1 um so we get
knight to d3 check instead king to e2
is the idea see a trade of knights on e5
and finally black just captures on e6
rather than allow bishop f7 with check
we get knight to e7 and now after knight
to d2
like it's it's pretty simple here this
pawn on c2
is more of a weakness now than it is a
strength
um black's king is stuck in the center
and it's it's just busted
queen d5 was the first move by hikaru
you have to get rid of this active queen
on e6
but unfortunately white is just simply a
material here we saw takes takes
knight e4 and magnus converts this one
pretty easily i don't want to spend too
much more time here
knight f3 to e1 and this pawn will fall
we see many many chess moves and a
winning rook end game
to top it off just too much went wrong
in the opening here for
karu and finally we see resigns in the
king and pawn end game of course king e4
is unplayable due to f6 same with king
f4
and that'll be that'll be the match so
that is the first kind of typical magnus
acaro game that i wanted to show
for some reason hikaru just never really
could get off the ground in many of
these games
now that's not to say hikaru never had
any chances and i'm about to show you
what might be the saddest game of karo
nakamura's career
and of course that's me guessing we all
have many many sad games in our chess
careers
but i struggle to think of a game
sadder than this for hikaru nakamura i
think at this point
hikaru's record against magnus was
something like zero wins
eight or nine losses and you know of
course
a slew of draws as all the top players
have against each other
and then he comes out and he plays plays
this game
so this one of course was played at the
zurich chess challenge in 2014
and this time we see hikaru with the
white pieces so
what does caro do he plays d4 we get
knight f6 c4 e6 knight c3 bishop b4
and wouldn't you know it hikaru plays
the f3
nimzo that's right hikaru knows
hikaru knows what's up he knows what he
has to do
in order to uh to take down the world
champ
and in this case he chooses the f3 and
enzo one of my favorite openings
uh and magnus plays the move d5
now i've spoken a lot about these lines
in my chess openings explained lecture
series
and we're actually going to see magnus
adopt a line that i was not so fond of
uh we're gonna see him play the
strange-looking move
bishop back to e7 so
the quote-unquote main line the most
common line goes with bishop take c3
and then really i think the the only way
for black to equalize
is with this knight takes d5 line i
don't
so much like the e takes d5 stuff for
black i think white gets an advantage
in most of these lines but instead we
see bishop e7 and this is actually a
very very interesting line
with the idea of allowing white to
expand in the center
with pawn to e4 but in return going for
immediate counter play
on the open dark squares and this is
going to be pretty different
than the four c five lines because
in the lines where black plays four is
c5 we get a
closed type of center where yes black is
fighting for the dark squares but you
know everything is remaining
pretty locked down and we're going to
wait for some pawn breaks to open things
up
now compare that to this line when
things are immediately going to be
getting opened we see
de4 ed4 and now there's actually
two moves here in my database the lead
chess database
e5 which was played in this game has
been played over 300 times
meanwhile c5 the other way of
challenging the dark squares
has been played just 19 times however
i'm of the opinion that c5 is a much
better move and black is in pretty
serious trouble
after the quote-unquote main line of e5
of course c5
making an appearance in this year's i
guess last year's
now extending into this year's
candidates tournament uh between
uh fabiana caruana with whites and alex
sancho
with uh black and fobby ended up winning
this game but alexianco had a very
decent position out of the opening
in this case though we're talking about
e5 the much more common move
and the move magnus chose in this game
we get d5
now bishop c5 and like i said compared
to the four c5 lines we see
all these open lines open lines of
attack
into the position for black now the
trick to this line
and we're going to see that hecaro
manages to navigate this pretty well
is to make sure black never gets
permanent control
over the d4 square if black is able to
sort of cement
the pieces into d4 then white is not
going to be any better
but um if you follow the line that i
recommended in chess openings explained
white should get some advantage and i
actually recommended starting with
knight f3
in the game we see a karu choosing
bishop g5 instead
and here i think black definitely should
play h6 with the idea of getting an
early bishop d
foreign in this case though magnus
simply castles
and now we're gonna transpose to the
knight f3 lines and we see here
bishop g4 by magnus h3
by white is the common response we see
takes takes
and knight beat d7 and now the point
is that black is simply not going to be
able to maintain
this bishop on d4 without making a
pretty major concession
and we'll see that in a few moves so the
story of this game
is basically going to be that white
castle's
queen side and is able to pretty much
keep the
queen side locked down for the most part
in the meantime
we see white with all this pressure down
the f file
and able essentially to just rip things
open on the king's side
and acaro more or less coasts to an
easily winning position here we do see
bishop d4 by the world champion
but now the problem is that after knight
e2 there's no good way to maintain this
bishop
we see in this case magnus opts for the
very
double-edged move of c5 so the huge
upside to c5
is that yes you get to keep this bishop
here but this is exactly what white
wants to see
after black commits to this move of c5
there's not a good way to open things up
to attack
on the queen side of the board you kind
of need this pawn
in order to play a move like c6 and open
up the c
file in order to attack in fact the
computer here
recommends something like the move
rookie 8
and just actually sacrificing this pawn
outright
and going for these c6 ideas in
the near future it would rather do this
than play c5
and lock things down pretty sad stuff in
my opinion pretty sad stuff
so c5 locking things down magnus wants
to keep the pawn and the bishop on
d4 we see g4 by white a5 now by black
but of course this is not going to be
enough for active counter play on the
queen side
white now plays simple chess king to b1
and uh i just want to say for reference
here this is like
plus one and a half to plus two for
white but against the world champion
there is still a lot of chess left to be
played and we're going to see akaru
actually find some really really nice
moves so i just want to point that out
we're not coasting to a win just yet
it's just that strategically
our plan is very easy to play with white
and magnus is going to have to work very
very
very hard in order to create threats on
the queen side however we'll see that he
does have some good ideas
rook a6 is a classic way of both
defending your king side
and lifting the rook for some tactics in
all
in many f3 nimzo lines actually and we
see magnus employing that here this was
the point of
a5 but simply knight g3 is just way too
easy
for white look at all of these holes in
black's position
g6 now by magnus is kind of forced you
just can't let this knight exist on the
f5 or h5 squares
but now of course the g6 pawn is what's
known as a
hook so i guess i'll turn it over to the
chatroom here
how should we take advantage of this
pawn on g6
what should we do
how do you take advantage of this pawn
coming to g6
and yeah great wolf has the right idea
uh it's called a hook because it's
something you can sort of
grab onto and rather than you know a
fish
getting baited by a hook in this case
we're just going to latch onto it
and use it to open up things like the h
file so h4 h5
with ideas of taking on g6 at the right
moment
is exactly what we should have in mind
so of course hikaru continues now
with h4 we see a4 by the world champion
and this is where hikaru starts um sort
of showing his stuff here he finds some
really interesting moves
that i personally would likely not think
to play
so h5 looks pretty natural in this
situation
but in fact magnus is making a pretty
devious threat with this move pawn to a4
now after rook b6 black is gaining a
tempo against b2
and he's actually looking to plop this
rook onto the
the third rank here and use the active
counter play
on the queen's side in order to force
some pieces off the board
so of course we can't move this queen
out of the way or else we
are falling for some well okay this
hangs our queen
yeah so we can't move the queen out of
the way because this hangs rook takes b2
um and if we play the move rook d3
magnus i think is simply planning to
play queen b6
and what's the point well the point now
is that we have threats here
and he car or magnus in this case is
just looking to trade off some pieces
to sort of lessen the the blow of the
kingside attack
uh so anticipating all of this after the
move a4 hikaru actually doesn't play h5
he plays the subtle move rook h2
and as far as i can tell the point of
this move is simply to defend the b2
pawn
in anticipation of the move rook b6
but on top of that it's always nice to
have the rooks sort of on different
files
i mean different uh ranks in these sorts
of fluid positions
because it makes it very very easy to
double them up at a moment's notice
now of course if rook to b6 were going
to be played
what do you think we should do chat room
we played rook 8 rook h2 in anticipation
of this move
so what can we do if rook to b6 now
what can we do what's the point
what was the point
yeah strafed has the right idea with
rook d3
again we we are sort of just playing the
moves we had to play as a response and
the other line we're just playing them
first
in this case and now of course rick b3
is going to be sub-optimal on account of
the pawn hanging um and here
black's counter play is sort of just
entirely snubbed like there's there's
nothing
that you can really achieve here with
black
so we see magnus changing plans at this
point acknowledging that rook b6 is not
really going to work
uh magnus just plays queen to a5 and
this is the type of attack i like to
call putting all your pieces on one side
of the board
and hoping for the best that seems to be
the idea
magnus carlsen has in this case just you
know put all the pieces on the queen
side
and we'll come up with some threats
later a strategy i know well
uh and here hicaro again finds a very
nice move i myself
would be tempted to just play something
like h5 directly
but hikaru finds the most accurate way
playing bishop d2 first
making sure this queen is on a less
active square
such as c7 and now we're going to see
ikaru actually push
g5 and then h5 the knight comes back to
e8
and finally we see this move h5 that we
had been waiting
so long to uh to play making sure the
move order was perfectly accurate
uh now you might be thinking well wait a
second this bishop interferes with this
rook why doesn't black play
rook b6 and rook b3 and the answer is
black does play rook b6 and rook b3
but the difference now is that we've
played g5 and then
rather than being forced to play rook d3
and trade off some pieces
we just go queen g4 and continue the
attack
magnus now brings the knight over again
put all the pieces on the queen side and
hope you can make a threat someday
bishop e2 is now hikaru's response
again perhaps preparing to double rooks
we see knight to d6 now and
look out everybody magnus finally made a
threat he's going to take the c4 pawn
but the bad news for magnus carlsen here
is that taking the c4 pawn does not
quite come with the blow
that's about to come down the h file so
far hikaru has played
the simplest chess of all time just
provoked a weakness on the king's side
in the form of this hook on g6 and then
found the accurate way to take advantage
of the hook
and this is simply leading to a win
for the white pieces rook d to h1
is hikaru's idea
and now of course if you do take on c4
you can expect a capture
and a capture on g6 and you simply can't
take this pawn back if you take back
with the f pawn you're in store for
queen e6 check
and okay even queen takes g6 here and of
course rook h7 is made here
and it's just it's all it's all so bad
it's all
so so bad even rook h7 is winning
in this case um so rather than
knight take c4 let's put on our
swindlers hats from last week and see
how magnus try to create some chances
here so if you're black
you are staring down some very scary
rooks
on the age file and uh you need to find
some way to create some practical
chances so what do you guys think
in the chat room we're trying to swindle
our way out of this one
hello to manny in the chat
how do we start swindling here knight b
takes c4 i just talked about that line
manny it's not so good you get
checkmated in like eight moves
not so good sacrifice bishop exactly
andrew and goat
you know when in doubt just throw away
some pieces and make your opponent think
a little bit
so bishop takes b2 is a pretty nice
swindling try
if white gets a little bit too crazy and
takes on g6 here
we actually are getting a draw in this
case with bishop takes c1 check
and now finally knight b takes c4
how is this going to be a draw well we
simply aren't going to uh to get there
on the king's side in time we're just
not
breaking through with any kind of
immediate checkmate
and it's actually white who needs to be
a little bit careful with the king's
safety here
now of course you know no sane player is
ever taking on g6 here
you just take the free bishop and so
that's what we see in the game
and now we actually do see knight b take
c4
of course bishop takes c4 should be
played to
make sure that our bishop on b2 is
defended now we get knight takes c4
and h takes g6 so let's continue the
swindle here
how do we keep up the pressure as magnus
carlson
how do we keep up the pressure here
yeah manny has the right idea just queen
b6 you know
just make threats just make threats and
hope is basically the game plan here
for magnus indocaro continues playing
good moves
at this point so there are many many
ways to win the game here
pretty much everything is fine but we
see the nice move g7
by hikaru accurately calculating that
after rook takes b2 check
uh you simply play king to a1 and
there's nothing doing here for uh for
black there's simply nothing
to be done uh there's no funny
checkmates anywhere if you take h2
white captures back your rook is going
to be hanging if you move this knight
and uh it's just winning for white so
g7 nice move by hikaru i want to
highlight that this move is awful
okay this move is terrible and is
actually probably losing the game
so this is probably what magnus was
hoping for um
maybe you know in some world acara goes
a little bit crazy in place g
takes h7 but this is a really important
idea to be
aware of we wanted to use g6 as a hook
to open the h file so after h takes g
queen b6 the last thing we want to do is
play g takes h
because after king to h8 now suddenly
we've closed the h
file again and black is you know
actually quite safe on h8 here because
we have closed down the file
so important to note g takes h7 that's
like the one way
to uh to ruin this game we get g7
instead rook d8
magnus not yet capturing on b2 and
simply queen to h4
is again the right idea by
hikaru in this case magnus is going to
get to
take the piece back with rook takes b2
again we have to play king
to a1 here captures is checkmate
obviously
but after king to a1 black is now left
with these problems
on h7 rook takes each two for the moment
interferes with these pieces
but after rook takes h2 now queen to g6
is forced
and knight to f5 is just quite sad
really
for black's position we see this knight
coming in
the queen threatens to take on h7
the knight threatens to fork the king
and queen
with knight to e7 and as
a results pretty much all of black's
pieces are going to be entirely
immobilized here
magnus has to play this move rook to e8
in order to stop
knight e7 so the queen can't move due to
checkmate
the king just can't legally move and now
the rook can't move
due to knight e7 and so black is
essentially playing without any pieces
aside from this knight and now is when
things get a little bit awkward for
hikaru
he plays this move queen g4 which is
perfectly fine
it doesn't really do anything to improve
the position and you might note that by
removing
the threat of checkmate the black queen
is also now allowed
to move so we see queen b6
hikaru adjust the queen back to h3 now
the queen has to come back no other way
to deal with this threat
and now we see hikaru blow it all
so white to move and not
win can you find the move
that blows the win here everybody can
you find the move
97 doesn't win accurate accurate story
this one can be taken and this is not
checkmate due to king g7
but you know her car is a little bit
above blundering pieces
knight h6 okay so net h6 is actually
also winning for a white according to
the computer
it's definitely not my choice but
apparently this one is surprisingly also
good enough to win
because queen d7 is going to be quite
strong here
and like you know the the pieces are
still just quite strong
for for white here so knight h6 not the
best move
doesn't lose the game though
so jimmy and adam have both
found the move that doesn't win carl
plays this move d6
which is actually quite tempting it's
quite a tempting move right
you notice that this piece can't move
and that this piece can't move
and uh after you notice that you're sort
of tempted to play d7
and force one of them to move right
that's that's the basic idea here
uh the problem is that in this case
black actually has a very clever way
to sort of escape uh
most of the problems facing his position
here
and so it might seem very clear to you
that this pawn is attacked twice
and only defended once but the story
actually isn't that
simple so it does turn out that knight
takes d6 is the only move
but of course after knight takes d6
queen takes d6 would be a little bit of
a mistake
due to queen takes h7 with checkmate
so in fact uh after knight takes d6
magnus has to find something better so
why isn't black
just losing here down a piece
what's the story what's going on
what's going on here
and yeah goat again has the right move
it's rook to d8
and now unfortunately uh hikaru
is in this very very strange spot
where uh rook d1 check is actually kind
of a problem
actually kind of a major problem here
for white you really wouldn't expect it
with this queen sort of sidelined all
the way over on g6
but things are going to get pretty
awkward pretty quickly for white if you
play something like knight f5
so knight f5 and white is actually the
one that's getting checkmated
uh rook d1 check comes in you can't step
to b2
otherwise queen b6 queen b1 comes in and
if you step to a2
surprise surprise you're not actually
defending the e6 square
and pretty quickly now you are going to
get checkmated
in the exact same manner with queen b3
coming in
at the end and incredibly there's just
no good response to this for white if
you play something like rook d2
yes you defend the knight but you've
given up on this threat of queen takes
h7
and now of course black can in fact just
capture this
knight on d6 because you don't have
checkmate in the end anymore
and there's just no good solution here
there's just
nothing that's uh white can really do to
keep up the pressure now
hikaru tries to move knight to c4 which
is a good effort because now rook d1
check
king a2 is playable because queen e6 is
not check
but again now magnus finds a good move
because this knight didn't come back to
f5 simply queen takes e4
is on the board still keeping an eye on
h7 and beginning to swarm
around this white king and here is where
uh it goes from bad to worse so already
white is in quite a bit of danger here
you have to find some accurate moves in
order to stay in the game
stay in the game uh my personal favorite
way of staying in the game would have
been knight to b2
being kettling the knight and the idea
here is simply that you need to control
these entry points
for the black rook uh but apparently
knight to e3 is perhaps the
best way of going about this it just
feels a little bit more loose to cut off
your queen's
access to to the third rank apparently
though this is fine for white
instead we see a curve play queen to h5
which is just
you know very much a step in the wrong
direction you're vacating the third rank
and you're actually um yes defending the
first rank
but you're allowing the black pieces to
to get into the game
so black to move and win in this
position from plus
like a billion to uh to black winning
in two short moves
three short moves i guess
what do i mean by encoding the knight i
mean putting the knight on a square
where
a bishop would be fee and cutted
okay rook d1 not going to do it that was
the point of queen h5
rook d1 not going to do it guys this is
why carter played this move
queen d4 or c4 so queen
c4 is going to hang checkmate queen d4
is
check but i think uh white can maybe
oh sorry not not king to b1 just play
knight b2 there as well
against queen d4
yeah rook d1 not that winning it turns
out
and antoine actually has the right move
it's it's rook to d3 here so
maurice actually loves his aikido chess
which
is you know the thought that every move
you play
comes with drawbacks and sometimes the
best moves take advantage of those
drawbacks
so the queen vacates the third rank so
the rook enters
the third rank um the queen also stops
keeping an eye on the c8 square
so the rook leaves the back rank as well
and that is kind of the story here so
why is rook to d3 so powerful
well now we always have threats of rook
b3 if the king were to ever step
to the b file and in this case hicario
tries
rook to h4 and again hikar or magnus
finds the only move
uh in this case because it's kind of
forced with queen to f5
turns out queen to e1 check isn't going
to be good enough here
because you do have to keep an eye on
this h7 pawn so queen f5
is still winning now hikaru has to give
up on checkmate and start defending his
own king
with the move queen to e2 if you were to
play just some
kind of passing move like rook to h1 the
problem here
is that b5 is actually coming on the
board and this knight is not going to be
able to defend the pawn on a3
and that's going to cause you some
pretty major difficulties
so queen to e2 played instead but still
b5 comes on the board
and um in this case magnus plays queen
takes g5
rook takes a3 was also fine and magnus
now with an advantage
is once again going to cost to victory
down a piece
but in return has no fewer than 5 pawns
and the king is relatively safe and
i mean if you're a karu after blowing
the winning position that you had
you're just not ever gonna hold this end
game and we see magnus
simply push the h pawn down the board
and the e pawn down the board
and then uh in this position
hikaru went ahead and resigned with h1
queen
coming on the board so what was zikaro's
mistake he played this move
d6 but i don't think we ever talked
about you know what he could have done
to win
instead so that's my question for you
chatroom
white to move and win in this position
can you come up
with a winning plan most moves are
actually winning here
for white but it's tough to find the
actual breakthrough so that's my
question to you chatroom
light to move and can you find the way
to break through
can you find the way to break through
here with white
and while you think about that this uh i
wanted to say
is sort of the other uh prime example of
a hikaru magnus game uh in this case
hikaru did it he got out of the opening
he got a good position
and in this case this is sort of the
extreme where he was just
entirely completely crushing completely
winning
but that mental block against magnus
seems to come into play
once again and he just can't get the job
done
somehow someway magnus manages to weasel
his way out of it
uh dead channel says possibly queen to
c3 if the knight moves away
take the pawn to protect g1 so the
problem with moving the queen away i
think
is that black is just going to play the
move b5
and then with your queen over here on c3
the black queen is going to have
some mobility again as well not
something you really
want to allow
queen g3 rook h6 that's an idea i
haven't checked
surface level that does actually seem
pretty good let's see what the engine
has to say
about um queen g okay no i i expect that
um
yeah the problem with these queen moves
is that black is always going to play um
queen b6 we actually saw this in the
game here um in this position
uh cairo played queen g4 with the idea
of rook h6
and yeah magnus comes up with queen b6
in response so this is probably always
going to be
magnus's reply and now if you move the
rook of course
there are problems with your own king
so something better than queen g3
great wolf wants to go to the end game
and that's just psychotic great wolf
how are you going for the end game here
when your opponent's king looks like
this and you have a pawn on g7
absolutely not 97 doesn't quite work
it's not checkmate we actually took a
look at this move
because king takes g7 is going to be
surviving for black here
andrew says king to a2 and king to a2
doesn't blow the win
but it doesn't win the game game either
show me the breakthrough
what's your breakthrough idea
knight g3 knight h5 knight f6
might be a little bit wishful thinking
there might be a little too wishful
you're blundering your e4 pawn along the
way i think
uh actually maybe you aren't
maybe you aren't but maybe you are
giving up uh
something i don't know knight g3 do i
move the rook
uh knight g3 knight d6 is the idea and
the point now
is that we are able to find some counter
play over here perhaps
so maybe it's not so easy maybe we
should have some sympathy for
karu
all right so the chat is finally
arriving at the right idea
you know all things considered this d6
move doesn't look so bad does it right
we just we want to go d7 and we want to
win the game
and the idea is that of course you know
black can't immediately recapture
now of course in the game rook d8 does
somehow seem to work almost miraculously
right it
seems like with only two pieces on the
board we shouldn't actually be in that
much trouble
but white is in some sort of awkward
spot here so the trick is not to give up
on d6 this is sort of a lesson you can
take away in your own games
if a tactic doesn't work guess you
shouldn't sit there forever and ever and
ever trying to make it work
but you should also be open to sort of
men amending your tactics somehow
and in this case the best winning idea
is to simply play
the paradoxical move rook to h1
now what's the point of rook to h1 well
the point is
black can do absolutely nothing to stop
you from playing d6
and after you do all of a sudden now you
can just play knight takes d6
rook d8 come back to f5 and guess what
they're
you're not getting checked anymore
you're just not getting checked and
there's no way to stop
ideas of knight e7 here like you can
play rook back to e8
but now you're just up a full piece uh
as white
and so rook to h1 the sort of
astonishing move
that just kind of ends the game on the
spot
i should also say d6 by the way is
threatening knight to e7 as well not not
just d7 that was the move that was
coming to my mind
but of course knight to e7 just as good
here for uh
for white um and so rook h1 gets the job
done
king to a2 uh as someone in the chat
said
with a similar idea isn't quite as good
because
if we do play d6 here there is still
going to be
a queen e6 check we have to worry about
it turns out here that actually the
white king is
going to be pretty safe
but uh definitely this is a lot scarier
this is a lot scarier right i would
rather not allow this at all and just
have played rook h1
so king to a2 was actually a legitimate
mission as well but rick h1
super simple and then white would have
just completely crushed this game
so with all of this heartbreak let's
get back to the uh stunning
quote-unquote conclusion
of this rivalry so you know up to this
point
uh hikaru definitely saw himself as one
of if not
the top competitor for the world
championship title
he felt that he was the guy that should
be taking the crown
from magnus back in the early 2010s
and uh it all sort of was was coming to
a head right
at this point um not directly after this
game but leading into this next game
ocaro's record against magnus i i think
was zero wins
12 losses and you know a bunch of draws
as well and so with all this talk of
icaro you know getting up to number two
in the world
but perhaps being the first american
challenger to the unified world
championship
since the 1960s um all this talk
hikaru needed to win a game against
magnus carlson right
and that's exactly what finally happened
for hikaru we're turning now
to the 2016 bilbao masters the
tournament where it all happened
for hikaru where he finally finally
finally
gets some sweet revenge against magnus
and wins a classical
chess game so let's take a look here we
have magnus playing e4
hikaru goes for c5 and we're going to
end up
in some kind of open sicilian with white
doing some slightly funny things with
the knights
but eventually of course breaking
through with d4
and the knight coming to d4 and we get
some
sort of fiance variation for white
black fiend cuddling as well in a more
typical
dragon dragondorf type setup forgive me
if i don't know the technical names for
all
of these random uh random sicilian lines
there's just so many names
why do they name the sicilian so many
different things they all look like each
other too
but in this case white fiend kettling
black fiend ketoing
in the open sicilian and here we
actually see magnus
going way off book with the move b3
so apparently the way they typically
play these games
is to go a little bit more slowly with
white take control
of the g4 square bring the bishop out to
the most natural square
and just play some chess right gonna
retreat this knight keep pieces on the
board
and try to occupy the center with this
knight on d5
make use of this bishop support back
here on g2
that's sort of the typical way that
these games go
in this case though magnus is the one
playing some strange opening business
with the move b3 which is kind of bold
right you know
to open this diagonal in response to the
bishop sitting on g7
but magnus simply wants to contest this
bishop sort of as
quickly as possible so hikaru takes this
opportunity as you might expect
to try and break down these dark squares
before magnus can comfortably occupy
them
with bishop to b2 and so he's going to
do this with the move knight to c6
now perhaps a little bit more common
these days is the move bishop g4
trying to take advantage of the fact
that h3 has not been played
but i'm perfectly happy with how hikaru
chose to navigate this opening so we get
knight to c6
take take bishop b2 and now queen a5
so uh hikaru again just applying some
pressure to
these uh dark squares here looking for
some tactics
uh magnus plays the move knight to a4
now we do see icaru opting to occupy g4
with bishop g4
the queen comes over to e1 and we see
queen to h5 so this is some typical you
know
uh early 2010's cro nakamura stuff he's
keeping the queens on the board maybe
when he shouldn't to try and get some
stuff
on the king's side in this case queen h5
i think is definitely just a mistake
and the reason why is going to be shown
in the game i think here if black simply
captures on e1
black is not really going to have any
any trouble
in this game black doesn't really have
too many weaknesses to worry about
and in the future can just break in the
center move one of these pawns
uh at the right moment and without
queens on the board
without any you know distinct advantages
you know black black should be doing
okay here
uh for example if it takes back
something like knight d7
can test this knight we see bishops come
off the board maybe
um and yeah i just don't see a reason
why black should be worse here
but instead we get queen h5 now magnus
plays this move
f3 and we see bishop h3 by
hikaru trying to get the light squared
bishop off the board and again
some attacking chances on the king's
side and now
g4 by magnus is the start of some really
good stuff
for white here the queen comes back to
h6
we see rook to d1 and now g5 is just a
very awkward move
by hikaru sensing the fact that maybe
f4 g5 was going to be a bit of a problem
in the near future
for black uh hikaru tries to play g5 and
stealth himself
occupying these dark squares the problem
is
this entirely cuts black's queen uh sort
of off
from the rest of the board and for that
reason uh
white is going to be a bit better in
this position we see bishop back to c1
bishop g2 king takes g2 and now
queen to g6 so
uh if you have the black pieces here you
might be starting to get a a little bit
worried
with this queen on g6 and it's sort of
really important to understand
with both sides what black needs to do
to break free
if black can find a way to break free
then of course black is very happy and
can break free
but if white actually notices black's
idea to equalize and bring the pieces
back into the game
then you know white is going to be able
to try and stop
it so what is black's idea after queen
to g6 what is zikaro trying to do
to bring the pieces back into the game
great wolf says 12-0 magnus adopted a
car so of course
it wasn't 12 wins in a row for magnus
there were
many many draws streamed throughout 20
plus draws maybe 30 plus draws
in all the games that they played but
hikaru had not won a game and magnus had
won 12
throughout their career great wolf says
maybe h5
uh and yeah h5 is a reasonable idea here
for black but it's
not really going to do it right the the
queen is still going to be locked over
on the king's side here it's not like it
really wants to step to the h file
with a rook coming to h1 so quickly and
yeah jason does have the right idea
d5 is what black needs to be looking at
if black can achieve this move d5
break down white's light squared control
then all of a sudden
all of a sudden this queen is actually a
very very active piece
on g6 rather than the slightly stunted
piece that we're looking at here
so in the game magnus plays this move h4
which is actually not entirely wrong
uh h4 is is pretty nice to just start
making some threats
and force essentially g takes h4 by
black or else you know h5
is just going to be very very strong
pinning this queen to the h6 square
is not ideal so after g takes h4
the point now for white is that you have
entirely softened up these dark squares
for uh for black and you're going to
have some opportunities to push these
pawns a little bit later in the game
but that being said white has to do
something very very concrete in this
position
or else black is going to be able to
break free with this
this idea of d5 so white to move here
chat room
what's the best way for magnus to keep
an advantage
michael says d5 we can c5 and e5 though
and this is true and this is perhaps
something magnus should take advantage
of
to try and prevent d5
goat snog says c4 and c4 is actually a
perfectly reasonable move here i think
white is doing okay after c4 but there's
actually something a bit better
that magnus can do something a bit
better than c4
and yeah joseph has the right idea you
actually start with this move knight to
b6
the rook moves and then you can bring
this knight to c4
and rather than just trying to stop d5
through brute force
in this case we're stopping it meaning
with a pawn in this case we're stopping
it tactically with the knight on c4 so
of course d5
is just immediately losing to knight e5
when this queen
is entirely trapped on g6 so why is this
maneuver better than pawn to c4
well we are also getting this knight
back into the game from the very
sidelined position it had
on a4 and so after knight to c4
it's really quite difficult to come up
with moves
for black you can play h5 but white's
going to simply respond with g5
and all of a sudden you can tell you're
starting to get a little bit
rolled over here still no time for d5
with moves like f5 coming on the board
and white is simply doing quite well
after knight to c4
instead though we see magnus get a
little bit lacks and play the move queen
takes h4
and i'm not going to ask you to find the
way to break through with black here
of course we need to play d5 at the
first given opportunity
and after this black is no longer worse
and in fact white
has to be pretty careful in order to not
be worse off in the game
now in the game magnus unfortunately was
not very careful and played the move g5
trying to attack this knight trying to
make use of this f4 g5 plan
that we saw working a lot better with
the knight on c4
in this case though this isn't a threat
yet due to the pin and hekaro simply
takes on e4
starts ripping things open and this
attack is
sort of now all in for magnus it was
sort of a free attack
in the previous case but in this case
it's an attack in exchange for the
entire center
and if it doesn't pan out black is just
going to be much much better and that's
what we see happening in the game
magnus plays f4 we see just e6 in order
to stop
f5 finally c4 to stop knight to d5
but hikaru calmly coolly brings the
pieces into the game
rook f to d8 magnus of course is not
interested in trades he's going all in
on this attack
and hikaru again just very calmly
re-routes the pieces to better squares
and there's nothing magnus can do this
knight on d6 defends the pawn on e4
the f5 square is a bit of a hole and uh
black
is doing very very well with the extra
one pawn extra one pawn but of course it
being a center pawn is
pretty critical in this position we see
queen f2
and hicaro again takes advantage of this
pin with the move f5
cementing the extra pawn and black is
now i would say pretty much positionally
winning
we see bishop b2 knight f7 take take
into caro actually smooth uh smoothly
sails sails smoothly to a victory in
this game
with control of the d file the extra e
pawn
and uh now a perfectly safe king there's
just nothing to worry about
this move is check but hikaru moves back
getting out of check very high level
stuff rook f2
and now all of a sudden it's white's
king that is under fire
queen to h3 and nicaragua isn't even
happy here going for
what is probably a winning end game with
queen h3 simply queen to d1
understanding that this king on g2 is
far weaker than this king
on uh g8 uh queen to e3 now
and e5 is just nasty business
finally ripping things open uh now that
uh
black is ready of course if fe 5 were to
be played
there are many moves here knight takes
c5 is winning simply rook g6 is also
winning
with the point being that if her takes
f5 queen g4
picks up the rook and there's nothing to
worry about
so instead magnus plays queen g3 perhaps
anticipating
these queen g4 ideas rook to g6 is still
played
and the pawn on f4 dies queen h5 is
check
check check and now knight g5
and white is just checkmated at this
point we get queen b8 king g7
a few pointless checks but again the
black king
is far too safe here we see the king run
to h8
control of the diagonal control of the
rank and upon to block checks from this
file
there's really no way to get at this
king queen takes f5 is played
we get knight f3 check king h3 and then
queen to d6
is actually the last move of the game
with dual mating threats
no way to stop both queen g3 or even
rook g3
and queen to h6 both with ideas of
checkmate you can play queen g4 but that
obviously
is losing for other reasons uh and with
this
magnus or hikaru finally broke the you
know the spell
that he was under where he was just
unable to beat magnus
in classical time controls um
and they've gone on to play a few more
games believe it or not this
still remains the only win hikaru
nakamura has against magnus carlsen
in classically rated chess has not won a
game
since then in classical pretty
interesting stuff
to uh to see in my opinion so hopefully
you enjoyed
this slightly deeper dive into the
rivalry between magnus and hikaru
back in the early 2010s i'm a little bit
over time now so
i'm gonna log off here really quick if
you're watching live
please tune in to sabine's lecture which
is starting right now
maybe it already started go watch them
as always my name
is caleb denby and i will see you next
time
[Music]
you